pas question de confinement pour voir
vale malgré l'épidémie de kobe 19
comme lui de nombreux martiniquais ne
veulent pas céder à la psychose
il faut dire que le vide et s'est
s'appuyé je trouve que faut pas créer
une psychose
il ya quelque chose qui se passe ça
compte mieux quoi il ya des le
gouvernement fait ce qu'il faut l'os
admettons ça arrive est bon ce sera
soigné pour mort voilà c'est cause c'est
mieux parce que sinon s'il faut affolé
tout le monde s'en va ça ça et ça et
cela 0 quoi
d'un autre côté certains commencent à
s'inquiéter surtout depuis l'apparition
d'un foyer épidémique en italie est-ce
qu'on est particulièrement exposé oui ce
toit avec les touristes qui arrivent
c'est ainsi ça peut arriver très vite
c'est aussi à beaucoup de bateaux déjà
reçu d'autres bateaux donc on a un petit
peu peur on crie on a peur en effet en
pleine saison touristique de nombreux
italiens embarque à fort de france pour
les paquebots de croisière un vol est
même programmée depuis l'italie pour ces
croisiéristes alors sur les réseaux
sociaux certains en appellent aux
autorités pour annuler la liaison
aérienne pour la rs il n'est pas
question d'en arriver là pour l'instant
tous les passagers seront vus par les
équipes de la rs les flyers seront
diffusés à priori en italien directement
et des masques seront diffusés aux
personnes
l'agencé régionale de santé se prépare à
une éventuelle épidémie de kovy 19 sur
le territoire français pour l'heure leur
agence sensibilise les passagers en
provenance des zones à risque la
stratégie éviter l'introduction d'un cas
au niveau du port donc on reçoit des
déclarations maritime de santé chaque à
chaque arrivée de deux navires on les
examine et on a un agent du contrôle
sanitaire aux frontières qui va sur
place et qui
regarde si les il y a quelque chose qui
ne va pas sur le plan sanitaire ou kylie
a astreintes évidemment au centre 15 il
y as 30 au samu astreintes aux urgences
astreintes d'infectiologie pour pouvoir
bien examiné le patient et bien définir
le cas une filière dédiée est d'ores et
déjà mises en place au chu mais en cas
d'apparition de symptômes grippaux après
un voyage dans une zone à risque
la procédure est la suivante porter un
masque éviter les contacts appelé le
samu le 15 et surtout éviter de se
rendre chez son médecin